dites-moi quelque chose de sexy et
si je magasine ici tant pis je veux que
vous mettiez votre main sur ma robe vous ne portez pas
votre robe hmm
ah
conseiller si vous poursuivez cette route et que
vous vous êtes engagé vous finirez par
prendre des décisions morales qui  vous prendra
complètement par surprise vous ne les verrez
pas rentrer à la maison
Je n'ai pas l'intention de prendre ça comme un
échange ouais une fois l'affaire
semble instable Je vais bien J'ai juste besoin que
vous soyez sûr que vous êtes enfermé  et
je ne connais pas
ma recommandation de toute façon conseiller ne le
fais pas bien je suppose que je suis un peu
surpris par la nature prudente de cette
conversation
si tu n'es pas là tu dois me le dire garçon
parce que tu ne sais pas  quelqu'un te dit
savoir ce qu'il veut c'est pourquoi